all right guys
bang bang i've got my little brother
here we're about to
oh he's already max i call him my little
brother well you're my little brother
right
true but you got to say that but we
you're not taller but that's fine uh we
could say my younger brother not little
younger brother he's still littler than
me uh let's get into it though you have
blown up on the internet congratulations
great job
thanks let's start with uh some of these
viral threads you've had then we're
going to talk about a bunch of
professional athletes that are investing
uh we've got some inside information
maybe we'll reveal uh and then we know a
bunch of people who've been buying
bitcoin in the professional sports
arena that we're gonna talk about as
well but first the viral threads
uh i don't know where you come up with
this stuff i don't know if you steal the
content you borrow it you come up with
it yourself but it's good
and uh you had one recently where
there's a fan
who basically gave a team alone and then
and again with 300 million dollars
yeah the gambling one gambling well he
was a sports gamer all right explain it
all right let's start uh
so european soccer right there's
different levels promotion relegation
and uh much bigger than in soccer in the
us yes of course yeah so we're talking
like premier league right and then
levels underneath that
so the way it works is uh a lot of times
you'll hear like billionaires in the u.s
right they'll come over and they'll buy
teams and they'll try to spend a bunch
of money and get them promoted and
because with promotion comes tv money
and
the same stuff that you would see in the
nfl and the nba and all this stuff right
so so it's a pure investment
for most of them yeah some of them it's
you know fun or whatever but a lot of
these guys all want to make money
similar to what they want to do with the
nfl mba and have fun doing it
um and all that so this guy matthew
benham
he was he grew up in in england he went
to university of oxford in like
late 80s 90s early 90s
and he was a sports gambler so he worked
like 10 years in finance he was a
physics major really good with numbers
he got hired by a sports betting company
to do predictive models with analytics
i was really good at it basically did it
for three four five years
had a falling out with this guy called
tony bloom who was like he's a known
sports gambler one of the bigger guys in
the world that good guy bad guy
uh i mean questionable yeah i mean like
everyone has their opinion on him i
think but like he won a lot so
so he's a good gambler good guy if
you're a gambler you're a gambler
yeah okay yeah i mean that's fine
whatever your opinion is on that right
but
uh so some people claim he stole the
models from them some people claim that
they got it they don't know what the
falling out essentially was and it's not
really public
but they had a falling out they hate
each other he left tony bloom kept on
with the company
uh and he goes and he starts matthew
venom starts gambling his own money
really successful two three year run
where he makes millions of dollars again
they don't know how much exactly but
not a million not a hundred plus million
but somewhere kind of in between
so we're really going to come on here
and say it's somewhere between one i
mean a lot of money
right like i'm not saying it's uh i
don't know if it's
it wasn't 500 is my point right so he uh
he gets a lot of money he starts his own
company doing the exact same thing
basically tony bloom was doing
uh predictive analytics helping people
consult for gambling right you go to him
you say
hey i want to use your models you're
really good at this obviously like show
me how to win
where the edge is all this kind of stuff
so he makes a lot of money doing that he
eventually now runs in exchange he's the
ceo of a betting exchange et cetera
but basically what that afforded him to
do was go buy a team
and he didn't buy a team at first but
his hometown team brentford
uh was the club that he grew up rooting
for as a kid
went to games when he was 10 11 years
old i think it was 2007 or eight they
got in financial trouble
they're a lower tier club so they have a
small budget you know
the economics aren't great at a lot of
these places uh so basically they're
gonna go under
he says all right the fans want to buy
the team so the team doesn't go bankrupt
uh i'll provide a 700 000 loan so the
fans can buy the team
and uh if you guys uh pay me back by
2012
five years um you'll keep going you'll
own the team whatever
if not there's a clause that it converts
to equity and i have the opportunity to
purchase more of it right and i can own
fully
full control of the team 2012 comes
along uh team's still really struggling
financials weren't doing great they're
struggling to get by
still so he converts it to equity buys
the rest of the team
okay how much money total do you think
we he spent to get the whole ownership
it's tough to tell but maybe a couple
hundred million
maybe less couple hundred maybe fifty i
don't like it
they don't really know because there's
he bought it in pieces right so the way
a lot of these work is you buy out
shareholders as it goes on
so the team maybe owned 50 at the time
or 51 and he was slowly buying out other
guys so then when his option came up he
converted it
so the aggregated price i don't know 50
million 100 million something like that
right so uh but not billions so he
he buys the club but he takes a
completely different approach so a lot
of these guys they come in and they
spend a lot of money for two three four
years to basically try to get promoted
as quickly as they can
yep and the way you get promoted is
finishing at the top of your league if
you're in the fourth division
you get finished at the top two you get
promoted you have to finish at the top
two again and et cetera so winners
advance basically
yeah losers lose yeah completely
different than the model we have here
where it's closed and
and everyone kind of stays in all 32
teams say in the nfl regardless if
they're good
if you're terrible you just get the
first pick right so completely different
but uh he takes a completely different
approach as to kind of how he's going to
make the team better he's like
really good at analytics let's try that
so if you think moneyball here with
everyone knows ball right the oakland
athletics where uh they came in and they
used analytics to kind of
drive their reasoning on to why to sign
players so he does the same thing
which has historically been like a no in
soccer in europe because they think it's
a game of finesse and analytics don't
really tell you that much and it
matters much more than that sounds like
a stupid perspective of course right so
there's there's
people will argue you know 100 till the
death on both sides but
that was his theory so what he does is
he doesn't only just run numbers
starts firing all the coaches that don't
believe in it right hires guys that
don't have this great background but
they believe in the numbers and they'll
listen to him and all this stuff
he buys a smaller club i think it was in
denmark and he pays like 10 million
dollars for this club
and 10 million dollars a lot of money
but he basically used it as like a
proving ground for his concepts so he
would try all these things there
and if they worked he'd bring him over
to the bigger club got it so it was
basically like kind of a minor league
for his
his uh his bigger club so what he did
was
he didn't care about wins and losses he
literally he's famous he wouldn't even
look at the league table of the
standings
he was just like that doesn't matter and
what he would do is he would look at
expected goals how many opportunities a
player was creating
uh stuff like that just key performance
indicators that would tell him whether
the team was improving or not
so that went on for a few years uh the
most drastic change that he's famous for
is he
a lot of these teams have youth
academies that
uh essentially like barcelona or any of
these other you know
premier clubs uh by the time you're like
five ten years old they're already
recruiting you you're playing for them
you make your all the way up to the big
team etc
he was like we're not going to do that
anymore we don't have the time patience
money whatever to invest in all these
players for this long
we're instead going to delete that team
remove them
yeah delete remove whatever that's why i
went back to remove
and we're gonna have a b team right
which is guys 19 to 23 years old 22
years old whatever
of basically cast offs from other clubs
so guys that played for these other
premier league teams
and were deemed not good enough not
worthy not didn't get minutes right in
games
uh and they're gonna come to our club
we're gonna use them and play them
and his theory behind that was that you
needed 35 games to be able to determine
if a player was good enough
right what do we know why he came up
with 35 that's just i
it's not really clear but it's one of
his models right so you got to remember
this is all
based on his predictive models that he
was using for gambling right so he took
those same models and was applying them
here
um and it's funny because tony bloom
actually owns a premier league club too
so people are like they joke like he
just followed the same same protocol of
what he did there
uh and tony bloom's club was promoted
they've been there for a few years now
so so same thing
uh but yeah he he uh basically his
theory was 35 games
and he would get all these players to
come in and what he did was he would
give them opportunities
sometimes it worked out sometimes it
didn't but the ones that worked out he'd
buy him for a million bucks two million
bucks and he'd sell them for 40 million
bucks
right so that was how he was able to
turn a quick profit pretty pretty easily
and then he was using that money to
reinvest in the club and do the same
stuff so a lot of these concepts ended
working out he had three four five maybe
even more chances get promoted the team
ended up losing a lot because the way it
works is if you're in the top two you
automatically get promoted then three
and four play for the final spot
so he lost that kind of playing game a
couple times but this year he won it
so they're going to premier league next
year and what that comes with
is anywhere there's you know it depends
on kind of how much
merchandise you're able to sell and
concessions and they just got a new
stadium and all this stuff but
uh most estimates have it around at
least 250 million dollars in year one
additional which is way more than his
budget right now
uh and it could be 350 400 500 depending
on if you stay
two three four five years right so the
longer you stay up the more money you
make
but it's mostly just tv revenue right
now you're playing uh manchester city
you're playing all these bigger
all these bigger clubs so the joke is
right like a gambler took seven hundred
thousand dollar loan and turned it into
350 million dollars
so that's when people really enjoyed
right just i think piece part of it is
the gambling part which everyone kind of
uh but gambling and investing is the
same thing
i knew you were going to go there right
yeah
i mean it's risk reward you're basically
looking at
data if you're a professional gambler
not i mean there's people who just go
when they're drunk and they you know bet
on something and
yeah they lose yeah right that's a good
point because some people were like
why are we uh you know putting a gambler
up on a pedestal and praising what he
did what's different than him in an
alcoholic and it's like they're way
different right like he was using
analytics and numbers and intelligence
really to
uh drive a return through a different
market which is similar yes to your
point
yeah i mean a hedge fund manager looks
at data and then they risk capital
for a return and they understand the
risk that they're taking they try to
find
edge right and they try to find some
sort of uh data point or signal or
whatever that
this has lower risk and higher return
than some other opportunity and they're
either right or wrong and the market
rewards or punishes them
same thing here uh where you're
essentially doing the same thing you're
looking at all the data
you're risking capital you either win or
you lose market rewards or punishes you
and if you have a significant advantage
in the data
when you're gambling it's incredibly
profitable
same thing in the stock market right if
you could figure out something that
other people haven't figured out yet
until it gets commoditized away it's an
advantage well i would say that two
things on that is one
significant is five percent in gambling
right like you only have to be five
percent better than the average model
and you can make a lot of money on it
because just the the way the odds work
but outside of that it's clearly the
same thing because he used the same
models for gambling that he did for the
team investment
right like he was using the same stuff
and just you know you altered a little
bit for kind of the outcomes
uh but he was using the same models and
the same analytics and data he just used
it for two completely separate things
i don't know if you've done this if not
you should do a thread on this uh have
you seen the susquehanna
uh investors susquehanna investment
group uh sig
uh they started out horse betting yeah i
haven't seen that but yeah
they used to go to the horse tracks and
that's how they originally got started
was they were basically
uh they figured out a bunch of
mathematical things uh and they would go
bet and they would win a bunch of money
and then somebody was like hey man
you've
that works for horses like you should
look at stocks yeah and like now they're
a huge market maker and investor and all
this stuff
um all right what's one more thread
that's gone viral that uh that
people really enjoyed um well you have
one of mine
do you not remember anyone i mean i
remember them but what's your favorite
one
recently um i don't know dude i gotta
like
you gotta think about it yeah like uh
what did i do recently
um the mcgregor one's great all right
what's that one
uh the mcgregor one was great conor
mcgregor conor mcgregor yeah
conor mcgregor's story is just cool
because like it's like a movie right
we should call out there's a lot of
people who don't like conor mcgregor
there's also a lot of people who
like him and then there's a bunch of
people in between who say hey there's
some stuff he does that i don't like but
i also respect me
the hustle the middle one i'm in the
middle all right so i'm probably in the
middle as well yeah
and right like uh i think it goes both
ways right like
he's had allegations of crimes and all
this stuff that i i don't know if he did
or he didn't do but i don't necessarily
obviously agree with uh the punching
people in bars stupid stuff right
but when it comes to his ability to
promote himself and uh make a living and
doing all these things
as a fighter his superiority within the
case clearly works extremely hard at
that and all this kind of stuff right
and just the the ability to distinguish
himself as a personality right there's
hundreds of you know thousands of ufc
fighters that were unable to do what he
did right
and he's really transformed the sport
not only from his ability but his
promotion
is he like the muhammad ali of the ufc
like
from a uh branding and a promotion
standpoint that's what i was gonna say
is like
he's clearly not the best fighter right
i think that's been proven he's lost
multiple matches in a row and all this
kind of stuff but
um from a promotional standpoint he's
the biggest ticket by far
okay not even close all right so what's
his story so uh he grew up in ireland
right um he was uh from a family that
was just not uh super wealthy or
anything like this right he
he blue collar family moved towns when
he was younger um
16 years old got into ufc him and
another guy chris egan they were uh
mixed martial arts right not not ufc but
like
mma so he actually started boxing he
would go to the uh to the gym
and the reason why he started doing that
was because he was getting picked on
right so it's literally like a movie
right like he was getting bullied he
i think the stories he walked home from
school one day and uh they threw like a
rock at him or something and then they
came up to him
and his first thought was so he went
home he said he sprinted home didn't
look back like just scared
he goes to school the next day he went
to school every day from then on with a
dumbbell in his backpack like
a weighted dumbbell and he was like yeah
like y'all came at me once but if you
try it again like something's gonna
happen
uh and obviously he realized pretty
quickly like that was dumb and he
started going to boxing classes so he
goes to uh boxing was he gonna do knock
guys out of the dumbbell
exactly right so i don't know if it was
like the next day he started boxing or
like a month from that can you imagine
the teacher being like hey man it looks
like your backpack's kind of heavy but
yeah i got 30 pound dumbbells
clearly there were no books in there at
that point right so uh
he goes and he he starts taking boxing
classes his family
he does that for five six seven years i
don't think he was like competitive
boxing but he was training and kind of
doing all that stuff his family moves
towns uh he goes to high school in kind
of a different area an hour hour and a
half away
he meets another guy named chris they
start taking up mma right so they're
at first it's not like hey we're gonna
start training they just fall in love
with the ufc
so they start seeing people fighting ufc
it's really early at this point
um the ufc started in the early 90s so
it's it's established but it's not uh
you know the biggest ticket in the world
yet so they start watching the fights
practicing the moves they start training
et cetera um and he
basically is like okay i'm not going to
college uh i need to make
money i am not in any professional ufc
competitions or anything so i need to go
get a job so he starts plumbing he's an
apprentice for a plumber
right so uh it's funny looking at
mcgregor now and imagine that but you
know he was a young kid
and he was like riding a bus or
something right like every day so he was
he would wake up at 5 30 in the morning
jump on a on a uh
on a bus to basically the train meet a
random guy there that he
knew right it's like a construction job
so he's meeting these guys there that he
doesn't know and they would
scoop him up scoop them up they would
travel to the the to the uh the spot for
the day that they're working
work you know seven a.m eight a.m to six
pm at night all day long
and then he would have to either go find
time to train or you know do all the
other stuff
uh he was getting paid terrible and he
just jokes he's like i knew pretty
quickly it was not what i wanted to do
just like from the standpoint of he was
like my back was hurting these guys all
looked miserable
like he's like i totally respected the
work and respected them but just from
like a quality of life
didn't wasn't interested uh so he makes
a decision i
i think it was within like six months
maybe three months maybe even less where
he's like i thought it was like within
like two weeks he was like yeah maybe it
was even less and he's just like screw
it
uh i'm gonna double down on this
fighting thing like i'm gonna try it
right
and people gotta remember at this point
like he's 18 years old 19 years old
he doesn't have any jobs no income uh
lives at home with his girlfriend living
at his yeah his parents house with his
girlfriend in the same you know same
house all that kind of stuff they're
making him meals that you know the whole
the whole thing
and his family's not like super well off
either so there's you know he was he
jokes that he was letting the uh
he owed taxes to the government he was
that was on welfare and all this stuff
right and his girlfriend's working
uh to support both of them at the time
and he's just training all day long now
so he was like i couldn't train it first
now i'm gonna do it all day long and i'm
gonna make something of myself
so it's kind of a movie in the
standpoint of now everyone knows who he
is
uh but yeah he fought in in uh in
ireland for a couple
uh for a couple years didn't he lose the
first two fights
yeah so he lost it i think he won his
first fight but then he lost like but he
was like 4-0 or 4-2 and he lost
back-to-back fights
uh got down on himself he was hurt he
was out for like a year and then he came
back
and that's when he won like he basically
there's a few stories about kind of what
motivated him when he was away he read
some books and stuff and he claims like
my mindset just changed he he claims he
just now he's like an animal where he's
training all day doing all this stuff
uh but yeah he comes back gets signed by
the ufc dana white flies over sees his
fight and he's like dude this guy's nuts
you know what i mean like he was just
like because he was doing the same stuff
he does now which is the funniest part
is he was literally doing the exact same
stuff like running around the ring
screaming jumping on stuff
press conference the same thing you know
like and uh he was a star
who just didn't have the stage yeah and
like there's stories of him
just like you know talking trash to
people at the weigh-ins and stuff and it
was just like
he wasn't mcgregor so everyone was kind
of like this is weird but now it's like
you know it's genius
uh so dana white sees him and he's like
this guy's a star like
like i gotta just put a camera as long
as he can live up to the hype like in
the ring like
total home run uh so he gives him a
contract for a couple ufc fights
his first fight is actually a hilarious
story because he wins
gets knockout of the night and knockout
just so people understand
if you fight you get a guaranteed
minimum yeah if you win
that point is minuscule it's your first
fight 20 grand yeah 10 grand whatever
uh if you win you get like a winner's
bonus
and then there's like for the night of
across all the fights a knockout of the
night
with a couple of bonuses and if you get
the knockout
of the night then you basically you got
uh paid for winning and you gotta pay
for the knockout yeah it's
an additional bonus basis okay right but
it's bigger than bigger than the other
one so he wins knockout of the night
uh and he gets a sixty thousand dollar
bonus and at this point
he had never seen that much money right
and there's people gotta look it up
there's a video of it he stands up
uh at the thing and he just yells and he
grabs a microphone yeah uh i think it's
uh
dana white 60 g's baby
and he just and dana's like told you
home run
i was like this is great and uh and the
best part about the whole story is i
think he bought his girlfriend a car
with the 60 grand right like
didn't save it didn't say it didn't do
but
whatsoever just like yo i'm buying you a
like a range rover
yeah yeah and uh and it's funny because
people know i'm not right he was the
highest paid athlete in the world last
year uh
which based off a few business deals
that you know we can go into we can't
but basically he's obviously good with
his business and his money and all this
stuff but that was just his mindset was
like he was an entertainer you know what
i mean he was just like
dana60gs went and bought a car he's
celebrating and all uh if anyone's seen
his
i don't know if you've seen his uh
documentary on netflix it's notorious
yeah my favorite part of the whole thing
is he wins one fight literally the first
fight i know exactly what you're gonna
talk about
he's on the ipad he's on the ipad like
sitting on the toilet taking an
interview
and he's just yelling ariel helwani
right yeah and he's got the sunglasses
on
and he's just yelling i'm the best in
the world all this stuff i'm gonna be
world champion
world champion i'm the best in the world
oh it's incredible and his girlfriend's
like in the room in his parents house
and
she's like she's like she's like you
literally won your first fight you got
paid 60 grand now you think that you're
muhammad ali
exactly exactly and it's it's great from
an entertainment perspective obviously
but honestly i think he truly believed
it too right
well he ended up and he did become the
world champion game the world champion
multiple weight classes all this stuff
right and uh and
off out of the octagon uh he's done
extremely well he had the uh
kind of the the liquor company the
whiskey company proper 12 that he sold
this year
highest-paid athlete in the world right
so all right so how does he become the
highest-paid athlete in the world
yeah so he makes uh you know
pay-per-view-wise maybe a few million
bucks a year on
the best years when it comes out of the
ring he made a ton a ton a ton of money
150 million dollars plus when he fought
uh mayweather but that's kind of once in
uh
okay so take out the mayweather fight
for a second he made 180 million last
year
yep and of that 180 million how much was
in the octagon versus outside a few
million in the octagon so 5 million 10
million
yeah and everything else was outside
yeah and most of it is uh
you know in a typical year maybe he
earns 10 15 20 million dollars on
endorsements kind of just like hey
your typical stuff promote our products
monster energy all the typical ones that
you would uh you see in the octagon and
all these other places
beats all those but then he did the
liquor company right the whiskey proper
12.
which uh was genius because obviously
you've seen a bunch of these pop up with
uh
aviation gin and ryan reynolds and the
rock and you know all these different
ones that people have had just massive
exits
and he was probably like in the middle
of that we see a lot more now and there
was a couple early ones that really
were successful he was kind of on that
second tier of like hey
there's a blueprint for this i'm gonna
team up with the right guys who have
done this
uh and we're gonna go attack ken austin
ken austin yeah and
uh what they did was exactly that he was
just promoting it right
and had a deal in place with kind of
distributors already where it was like
hey you guys are gonna manufacture this
you're gonna distribute it you're going
to kind of just plug and play it into
your network already
and we're going to promote the hell out
of it we're going to see how much we can
sell and they had milestones
if they hit they would exit the business
and those were hit over the last
you know three four years where hey we
hit this milestone by an additional 20
of the business we hit this one by an
additional and those aren't the correct
numbers necessarily but they're
uh just an example of kind of how the
deal worked and
this year was the last exit of the deal
he's still a promotional partner i'm
sure there's still kind of maybe a
little bit of equity or whatever
at least kind of payments for marketing
and stuff uh but he made like 150
million dollars
which is for six feet
right and uh the craziest part about
that whole thing for me is like
never in the wildest imagination would
you think that a ufc fighter would be
the highest paid athlete in the world
it just shows the branding the promotion
the marketing and what he turned himself
into
uh from all of that right but the
highest paid ufc fight in the world
maybe usually max makes 5 million 10
million a year outside
boxers make more than the ufc folks and
the whole nine yards yeah i mean there's
a reason why uh
jake paul and logan paul got into boxing
not yet one because they'd get killed
but
two uh because the money's obvious how
bad would it be if they stepped into an
octagon
with a guy like mcgregor yeah sure just
well like best of the best
yeah that'd be bad it would be really
bad yeah all right and so
that's also why the celebrity boxing
matches are so interesting is because
they're basically
they're poking the bear right both jake
and logan uh
are poking the bear trying to get the
ufc fighters saying hey you're not
getting paid enough money come over here
and do celebrity boxing yeah
and what's unique about it is a lot of
the mma folks actually aren't good
boxers yeah right
and this is coming from somebody who i'm
not a good boxer either right so like
it's just
they're much more well-rounded they're
not an expert at boxing
boxing is one of the many uh disciplines
that they have to be good at to be a
good ufc fighter
and so what they're essentially trying
to do is is almost get the ufc get the
names to come into the ring
uh and do boxing which jake and uh logan
are
better than they were a year or two ago
i i don't know we went to the fight like
i was pretty impressed with they're
obviously not bad boxers going eight not
eight rounds with floyd mayweather like
i don't think any of us
expected that i was gonna say it's also
like threading the line a little bit too
of like
hey i mean mayweather is an extreme
example of going the full way
uh but what what jake has done really
well is like i'm gonna be a boxer i'm
gonna be
legit to some degree of like you know
fighting real fights and training hard
and doing all this stuff but i'm gonna
fight ufc guys that
you know maybe like you said lack a
little bit of that can we talk about ben
askren
yeah ben i love you
i need to know did you train
[Laughter]
ben i love you to death you're the
you're the smartest person i know
because you got paid i know you got paid
everyone knows you got paid
but we need to know you think he trained
i just i saw the video of him running in
his yard in the snow and stuff like that
but outside of that i'm not sure he
showed up
uh on the way and those those photos
were viral it was all time yeah i don't
know i saw a picture of ben and amy
amy's his wife they were walking in the
hallway afterwards they were laughing
that looked like the face smile that
looked like the face of a mad genius
to me we got paid that was that face
yeah i love you ben
if that's what happened you're the
absolute og of all of this
uh all right let's talk about some other
investors that are athletes
uh i know that you've gotten to know
rich kleinman and
uh 35 ventures and a bunch of what
they've done with uh kevin durant
uh what what what is rich kliman doing
let's just talk about rich rich is an og
i know
you know him too he's great right he's
he's awesome he's uh what's his deal
he manages kevin he runs 35 ventures
their their venture capital uh kind of
investment shop and what do they invest
in
everything technology they 50 100 plus
investments at this point right and some
big wins coinbase
uh uh what was the food delivery startup
uh
doordash right so they they invest in a
bunch of companies they're investors in
dapper
all these you know these uh mostly
technology focus i would say
um but i think they do some consumer
products and stuff like that but he runs
that
boardroom which is their kind of media
arm of everything
uh sports business-wise but he's a busy
guy but he uh
rich kleinman forever will get my
respect because uh i saw him he was
doing an interview and he was sitting in
his corner office in new york city
and he looked just smooth and he had
sunglasses on while he was doing the
interview
and i said hey man nobody's screwing
with richard rich climbs the top of the
world he got sunglasses on on the
interview
yeah yeah rich is great and and they've
built a great business right like
on the court kevin obviously is a great
player killer
last night oh yeah well i don't know
what data is going to release tomorrow
uh the bucks playoff game last night i
think 45 points 17
assists 12 whatever it was right we only
played last night
jimmy neutron looking ahead uh i
promised i wasn't gonna make fun of him
the whole time but whoops
all right so rich and kevin how do they
get the deal flow like do
is it now just uh in the beginning it
was like hey let's work really closely
with venture capitalists and
we'll kind of invest alongside them and
now like they just built a name for
themselves so people come to them for
deals like how does it work
yeah i mean i'm sure that uh i don't
want to speak for them right because i
think their answer might differ to some
degree just based on kind of being in
the trenches on that but
keep playing golden state right so
that's kind of where you want to be at
least back then in
2017 whatever it was uh from a venture
capital perspective made incredible
relationships
and i think the people that i think the
thing that most people understand is
like athletes want to talk to vc
investors and
vcs want to talk to athletes right so uh
kevin was a natural guy that you know
they're sitting courtside they want to
talk to the players the best players all
that kind of stuff
so i think you naturally learn some some
of that through those relationships
you obviously get brought a lot of deals
through that you are interested
investing you want to learn you make
that clear to them they bring you deals
you talk to them you can obviously
provide value for kevin whether you have
kind of his own traditional uh
distribution on social media youtube all
that kind of stuff
or uh through the board room and kind of
all that kind of stuff
so i think it was a combination of hey
this guy can be super value for some of
these investments that we're doing
and then kevin being super interested in
the investing stuff how important was it
that he went to golden state for a lot
of this
i mean one from like a basketball
standpoint like
traditional fans love to hate on the
fact that he went there and teamed up
with all these players to win but at the
end of the day
uh i don't remember his exact quote when
he did it but it was just like
when the game's over and you retire and
it's 50 years from now the only thing
people care about is championships they
don't care about
who you did it with people forget all
that right like guys that are not born
yet they won't have any clue what the
heck happened to get him those champions
they just care about championships so
that's what he went and did he wanted to
win their style play all that kind of
stuff so from a basketball standpoint it
was great
investing wise he couldn't done anything
better right because you're teaming up
with world-class
uh investors out there you're meeting
some of the brightest minds in the world
and uh not only are you creating
personal relationships but you're seeing
the deal flow you're
investing alongside them they want you
in they want your check all this kind of
stuff
so i think it was just um amazing from
both perspectives basketball and there
and obviously
it worked out on the court and then off
the court with some of the exits worked
out too
they got a nice ass office in new york
city my favorite was the guy downstairs
yeah you wanna tell that story yeah we
uh we rolled up to the office once
and uh but the door was locked right
yeah so well joe and i went it was at
night too it was like
we met went and met uh rich at like six
o'clock yeah
at night yeah and when we walked up uh
you'd been to the office before right so
you knew where we were going
but we walked up i think joe tried to
open the door i didn't see this guy the
first time
and it was locked and uh while we were
waiting a second trying to figure out
you know is there a belt ring or
whatever i just looked uh
kind of at the street and there was a
black like suburban or escalade whatever
sitting there
and there was a dude uh who obviously
was
not just a driver he's a big dude uh and
i think he even might have had his
sleeves rolled up had like a tattoo or
something on his forearm
and uh he just kind of looked over at us
and there was a second there where i was
like
what's this guy doing here yeah like uh
like you could tell he was doing
something there but you didn't quite
know what it was
we didn't know was he there for us or
was he there for somebody else yeah
yeah he had that that look in his eyes
but uh and so when we went upstairs we
made sure that we told rich
hey man don't be sending nobody to come
get us
yeah and which he thought i saw him uh i
saw him later on a different time and he
was
he's like you know exactly what you
would expect uh
ex-cop right parks wherever he wants
he's got
takes care of everyone he's a mod yeah
he's a great guy right i talked to him
for five minutes he was awesome
uh but it was just funny seeing him the
first time and like what's going on here
all right the next person i want to talk
about is saquon uh
saquon barkley we've gotten to know him
uh
ken katz connor all these guys uh we'll
talk about danny boy hustle hard in a
second
you know we're gonna talk about him uh
but saquon is fascinating because
uh he is uh what you and i would say is
the best running back in the nfl
uh go giants and uh say do we have to
put a disclaimer on that no he just
facts it's like it is a fact sa quan
barclay is the best giants fan
running back um and now he's starting to
get really really interested in
investing so like maybe walk through
like take somebody like saquon as he
becomes more interested in this like
what's the journey for
uh an athlete to become uh an investor
and kind of get
much more um kind of exposure and and uh
deeper into those circles
yeah and i think it's not only what we
were just talking about with kevin but
what we've talked with saquon about
which is like you come in the league uh
you're making some money you're figuring
out what you want to do you get
comfortable for a little bit of time you
do endorsements you get your name out
there you build your brand
uh distribution all that type of stuff
right all the things that are important
when you start investing
so he's done that for a couple years now
and then i think it's it's what he's
really been trying to do is just build
those relationships right those same
things that we talked about kevin with
in golden state is like
you call up the five ten best investors
you know the guys that have the best
returns or women that have the best
returns on wall street and you say
hey look i want to learn i just want to
learn i don't even want you to give me
access
all this stuff and what you find is it's
the same thing they want to talk to the
athletes athletes want to talk to them
you build that relationship
they care about you because they're
seeing hey he really wants to learn and
then they start bringing new deals
naturally right and you get the same
access that they have and you provide
value it's not like they're just
any favors but saquon has a massive fan
base
especially when you look at it from like
sports technology companies and things
like that that
that he'll invest in over time he
provides tremendous value so i think
it's more about just
learning at first figuring out what you
like and what you're interested in
investing
and then seeing that deal flow from
these guys hey guys what's going on
before we continue with this awesome
episode i want to quickly talk about our
sponsor kraken
for the last 10 years kraken has built
one of the best platforms to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies online
they've got a brand new mobile app the
kraken app today you can go on and buy
bitcoin
or up to 60 of the most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world
and you can do that on the go 24 7.
all you have to do is simply download
the app connect your bank account
and you can get started investing with
as little as 10
it only takes a minute to get started
with the new kraken app you'll have your
portfolio in your pocket
you can track your portfolio see who the
winners and losers are every day
track your favorite project or just
simply look at the trading volume for
your favorite assets
it has all the features you need without
any of the complexity
it's simply the best place to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies
so go to kraken.com bang bang to learn
more
or go to your favorite app store and
simply search the word kraken and you
can download the mobile app there
kraken's been a longtime supporter of
this show so to say thanks it would mean
the world to me if you would go and
download their new mobile app
all right let's get back into this
episode i hope you're enjoying this one
all right
saquon love you you're going to be a
absolute genius
on the investing front let's talk about
uh our all of our favorite human in the
whole world
danny boy hustle hard yeah who maybe
first let's just start with
who is this well why don't we just tell
the story about the first time we met
him
which was uh so we went to dinner with
these guys and we were going out to new
jersey
right and we get uh danny boy who's the
driver
for say that's not danny boyce danny boy
hustle yeah sorry i don't want to just
do the first name here we're
danny boy hustle hard from new jersey
absolute
legend in the tri-state area
we were told we were told danny boy
hustle hard who for those that don't
know
uh drives a ton of celebrities ton of
athletes etc all throughout new york new
jersey
uh that anywhere you need to be in the
tri-state area danny boy hustle hard
i'll get you there in 10 minutes oh yeah
10
15 maybe but 10-15 minutes anywhere you
need to be he's got you and so when you
hear that you're like
man there's some areas where it might
take an hour and a half don't worry 10
15 minutes he's got you
yeah like i've never gotten to met life
in 10 minutes
so uh as part of the experience of
meeting him
he came to pick us up in uh in new york
city manhattan
and uh maybe let's just start with
literally how we knew
which car he was in in order to get in
the car with him so like me or you
uh we gave him an address right he's
i'll be on the corner
it's like dude i gave you an exact
address right which
one he doesn't want to turn on the
street yeah i'll just meet you at the
court typical
new york kind of uh personality and
driver right so meet on the corner so
we're out there waiting on the corner
and uh instead of a text or hey pulling
up whatever we see him
or here's the car yeah we're literally
sitting on the corner uh we see him pull
up
he almost goes down a one way the wrong
way back yeah the wrong way
backs out and parks sound like basically
the curb where the buses are supposed to
go
and just lays on the horn just lays on
the horn and not like a quick beep like
hey i'm over here like a hey this is me
come find me
and you and i looked at each other and
we're like i guess that's it yeah
yeah we're like no one else would do
that so that's him yeah
but then uh we get in the car yeah i
mean
say what's up he says what's up cheech
[Laughter]
multiple cell phones are ringing well
i'm like
and we had to go maybe 45 minutes away
yeah i think we got there in 25 minutes
how do we get out of manhattan
oh this is yeah so i mean to be fair
we knew two minutes into the ride that
craziest experience i've ever had in
manhattan
also absolute legend danny boy hustle
hard
he yeah he's unique as a driver cause
it's pretty reckless the whole time but
you're
completely comfortable the whole time
also like he's just he's talking he's
chatting and he's just doing his thing
he runs every red light yeah i didn't
know if we were supposed to say that
he i mean you know he is he's danny
hustle hard yeah he goes hard
uh and every single maneuver he uses
to get through that tunnel yeah
you're sitting there and you're like
this guy could win the indy 500. he
literally could drive a chevy suburban
and win the indy 500 that's how good of
a driver he is
yeah and the entire time he's doing it
he is making you
die laughing yeah and you literally feel
like you could not be safer yeah it is a
skill
he's great at it yeah way back too
had dinner with us and then yeah way
back yeah and we we probably even got
back quicker on the way back
my favorite thing that he does by far is
uh the entire time he just keeps laying
into
anything that you would think might be
controversial he has an opinion
[Laughter]
yo cheech let me tell you and i don't
know where that word came from but
cheech is
uh nomenclature for how he addresses you
it's just a cheech
yeah he seeks out those topics really is
what it is he'll like bring up a
question that ah that
is like controversial a little bit
you'll like kind of skirt it a little
bit to some degree and he'll just go
straight
on a scale of one to ten one not being
not funny ten being hysterical
where do you put him oh he's a ten oh i
think he's like eleven or two well
he's off the charts funny yeah we our
brother john is funny but like
danny boy hustle hard makes jon look
like a mime
yeah he's great yeah and the best part
about the whole you let me know if
you're flying in any time you want to
ride
i was dying yeah i was like yeah we got
your number all right
so uh danny boyhusselhard is
uh he drives all kinds of uh
professional athletes etc all throughout
new york city
legend if you do not follow him on
instagram highly
highly recommend the follow on instagram
uh literally you will be laughing on the
floor at how funny this guy is
but a bunch of other athletes also come
through some of them
are investors in bitcoin let's talk
about athletes who have decided to get
paid in bitcoin what exactly is going on
there who's done it and why are they
doing it
yeah so there's a few of them right and
i think uh
the the main guys that people that
everyone knows about are are russell
kung
uh sean colkin did it last russ i think
he took 50 of his salary right he said
it
kind of november of last year he's paid
like 13 million bucks a year and he took
50
of his salary in bitcoin yeah six and a
half million bucks a year said
pay me a bitcoin uh sean he actually
tweeted that too yeah pay me a bit and
then he said paid in bitcoin
yeah yeah how it started how it ended
right uh but so sean colkin
uh he was a tight end for the kansas
city chiefs same thing
he said i'm gonna take 100 of my salary
though so he's a uh
kind of a veteran minimum player uh
makes a million bucks a year said i'm
going to do 100 all million dollars i
want paid in bitcoin
um so i mean you know the way these
these things work like they don't
actually physically uh the team is not
buying bitcoin holding it on there kind
of balancing and paying them but the
transaction is facilitated
and they get paid in bitcoin via strike
via strike yeah
good plug uh hashtag investor yeah
strikes taking over the world yes so
they they el salvador the nfl whatever
you need we got
yeah so they uh they strike and and
they've been uh
taking their salary in bitcoin and part
of it is kind of like hey why don't you
just buy bitcoin like somebody
russ has been buying bitcoin for years
right so it's kind of like why don't you
just keep doing that and do the same
thing
but i think it's two things one like
they're opting out of of
of traditional the us dollar to some
degree right but also uh they're just
believers in it right and they're
showing they're making a statement
they're making a statement
and that's really what it is it's
statement you can call it marketing
whatever you want but really what it is
is this what i believe in this why i'm
doing it et cetera
so okay the same thing sean colkin same
thing the one i thought was interesting
was trevor lawrence
right where he said uh i'm gonna take my
endorsement uh the money from
uh definitely yes and oh black folk owns
block
yeah so blockfolio paid him his uh
basically what was equivalent of the
signing bonus of the deal all in crypto
not bitcoin other stuff right or was
some bitcoin some was bitcoin uh like a
third of it
bitcoin a couple other coins uh so he
got
parked he just went all in on all kinds
of weird coins no there was three of
them and i forget exactly what it was
but
uh they're serving bitcoin was one of
them and he took you know a third or
third i think what's up with the the
goat tom brady mine
let's just caveat tom two super bowls
yeah you're owen two in the super bowl
against eli manning i love you you're
great you gotta respect great players
yeah you multi uh super bowl champion
but against eli manning the best
quarterback to ever grace the nfl
as a giant uh your own especially from a
meme perspective
yeah i mean i mean eli manning is two
and oh against the goat
in the super bowl if you beat the goat
twice in the game
that matters then you're the goat right
whatever shout out eli
all right go ahead what do you think
about him and his whole uh bitcoin foray
i mean he hasn't you know come out and
said hey i'm taking salary and bitcoin
or whatever but he's got the laser eyes
on twitter
everyone loved it uh he spoke at the
conference he's obviously into nfts with
kind of the platform he's working on
everything like that
so i think it's the same stuff and and
the more uh one of the things that stuck
out to me was when
russ did the and he got paid and they
came out and said hey we're gonna pay
you and he was up big
and all this stuff and it was going
viral on the internet uh he was like i'm
having
tons of athletes reach out to me right
and he said the exact same thing when
tom brady did it when tom brady put the
laser eyes he was like all these nfl
guys are interested
one because it uh it legitimizes a
little bit right it comes out and he
says hey look
i'm invested in it i own bitcoin other
crypto whatever it is
uh but in our quarterback room we talk
about it every day he said uh our
quarterback coach has been in it for a
while he's
kind of you know got all of us on the
same train and stuff so when a guy like
tom brady does it whether you think he's
the best investor in the world or not
he's obviously super respected from kind
of a not only a football player but a
business perspective and kind of who
these guys look up to
so i think he was a major turning point
for people in sports of like
hey this is legit like we should go
check this out right
i don't want to put it on blast let's
not say the sport or the team
but uh we've been told a story by the
people involved so we know for sure it's
true
uh that there was a team that during
halftime uh
of important games they would be
checking their coinbase wallets so
they're going basic accounts
showing each other how much money they
made or lost in crypto and bitcoin
and literally the coach at one point
like hey put your guy put your phones
away like we got a game to play
at halftime yeah what do you do if
you're a coach in that standpoint
i mean you're like put your phone away
we have a game to play and the player's
like yo
coach making money you see how much you
see how much bitcoin i just stacked like
i'm out here like i see you
yeah what's fascinating to me though is
like some of these players do you think
that they would literally retire if they
like if they were a billionaire you
think some of these players would just
walk away absolutely yeah i mean
you got to remember too uh specifically
like football right like
because your body yeah uh saquon has
never said this so i'm not gonna speak
for him but a position like a running
back
you're getting killed out there right
you're constantly hurt you're rehabbing
you're doing search all this stuff like
that oh no man he's a guy
nobody touches yeah no of course like
he's he's an incredible athlete right
but just from the perspective of like
it's a physical game
if you're a billionaire at some point
you're like all right i don't really
want any head injuries concussions knee
injuries whatever
it is like i'm just gonna go chill and
retire right maybe you find something
else to do or whatever it is
but if you told these guys i mean guys
have literally told us not
those guys but like other guys they're
like yeah i'd be out
yeah so like it's yeah you know who we
should talk about uh that we haven't
mentioned yet
uh probably one of the funniest people
in the nfl is uh
sterling shepherd yeah uh
i'm gonna plug him for his
advertisements
cause this guy is hysterical and then
you look at his instagram
and he's taking photos with like bars of
soap next to the bathtub
with his kids and he's like yeah go buy
this soap
and one where i mean getting paid
yeah when we met him i was like these
are the same people
and not in like a he was like a
ridiculous perspective but he's just
hilarious right he's just like me or you
he's the normal guy hilarious and like
it's just funny seeing two way different
perceptions of
them but i think that's why folks there
are certain players that everyone
gravitates towards like man i like that
guy
right and maybe you can't you don't like
personally interact with them whatever
but like the authenticity comes through
it's probably also why the brands like
uh certain players right it's like oh
this person is really authentic they
uh the audience feels like they're
relatable they you know we don't have to
worry about them going doing crazy stuff
or whatever
and it just seems like a couple of
people that we've talked about like they
all kind of hit
those uh marks and that's why they get
the endorsement deals that's why brands
want to work with them all that type of
stuff
yeah 100 yeah i mean look he was uh
super personable obviously right like
super good guy but hilarious and he
relates well on the field he plays for
the giants that obviously helps he's
good at football all that
could you beat saquon or
uh shep in a 40-yard dash is that a
serious question
i don't know could you i could easy
let's go how much bitcoin
what's your 40 yard dash a split second
faster than either one of them
okay so uh saquon probably ran like a
four four at the combine oh well i run a
fourth three then
all right we'll we're gonna test that
out listen that's what i want and rather
than do celebrity boxing's uh
i don't need a box let's do 40 i'm
getting paid before i mean mayweather
even if he lost the match he got 30
million on his shorts like i'll run
against you take one do you believe that
sure let's go i mean he said it yeah
yeah whatever that's fine oh do i
believe that floyd mayweather got
30 million oh yeah i think that he
probably didn't count correctly anybody
got paid more
right like 30 mil on the shores then he
probably got to pay another 20 million
posting stupid stuff on the internet
then he got paid 10 million dollars to
show up to the bitcoin conference and
ethereum shirts yeah
i mean that was the best part he showed
up in an ethereum she was like dude
read the room a little bit but yeah i
mean it's uh at some point you got to
think he's like
over i mean he's probably not
overwhelmed i guess people are handling
it for him at some
to some degree but just like so many
things go into one fight where it's like
he was
he had the mass sponsor he was wearing
the face mask out there
he's like dude everyone's you know
testing wait let's go back for a second
now that i'm thinking about this i think
saquon would do it too if somebody
said that saquon and i would each get
paid 5 million dollars to do a 40-yard
dash who's going to pay you 10. listen
people would watch
it you race people it's got to be at
least competitive the whole thing about
the boxing why the boxing works
no i would smoke it no the the whole
reason why the box you really think
saguan could beat me in a 40-yard date
yes
wow okay you're not you're fired let's
bet a bitcoin on it huh
huh
well that came up he's like nah never
mind a sponsor could pay me to race
though okay
would you race too for money yeah yeah
that's what we should do we should do a
four-way race
shep saquon you and me loser
yeah whoever comes in last loser is
banished from the internet forever
winner gets five million and the other
two each get a million bucks so you're
definitely banished from the internet
you know and then i'm gonna win somebody
get five million dollars and the other
two you can get a million bucks do you
see uh win-win win and then you lose you
know what that reminds me of is
uh when rovell was trying to box darren
robelt was trying to box uh
uh pft from barstool that's not real
yeah you never saw this no
but his stipulation was there i forget
the exact amount
he wanted millions of dollars though and
they were like uh you know no one not
going to happen but
pft was like uh i'll meet anywhere
anytime anyplace
and if i win will box and if i win you
have to stay off the internet for like
it was like two years or something like
one or two years
like you just can't use your twitter
account or you it was either you have to
delete it or like you can't use it for a
specific repair time i forget exactly
what it was but
he's like uh yeah you have to get off
the internet and that was the deal
breaker for rovell he was like dude this
is my business
i have two million followers all this
stuff and it was funny because
it's true to some degree right like
that's what he does for a living but
obviously pfd was like dude you can't
use twitter anymore if pft
boxed darren ravel off the internet he
would be the hall of fame immediately
goat that would be pay-per-view right
like uh
but i think this is where the world's
going as much as i'm joking around about
the 40-yard dash whatever
i literally think that you me and let's
say saquon and shep could literally
create enough controversy around an
event
and literally each get paid seven
figures to go run a 40 yard dash as
crazy as that sounds
logan paul just fought floyd mayweather
and floyd mayweather made like 50
million dollars doing it and logan
probably made 10 or 20 million dollars
doing it yeah
like the world we live in now is so
different than the world we used to live
in and some of it
is it's an attention economy some of
it's just like the market's been
manipulated you know
like crazy and then some of it frankly
is just outright
who can draw like who can be the most
outrageous against each other
and just convince people like hey i want
to watch this slow car well you get
rewarded for
obviously building the audience and all
that kind of stuff but also just being
authentic and
wild to some degree right like uh uh i
forget who exactly it was but all these
ufc guys were like hey man we're getting
screwed you know uh logan paul just made
20 million dollars [ __ ] uh fighting
floyd mayweather like why can't i do
that and the reality is like because you
don't have a million people buying a
pay-per-view
well not only that but you don't have 50
million people on on
between twitter facebook you know all
these different social platforms and he
does he has this audience people that
are willing to pay and they sold a
million on pay-per-view right like
that's not even some ridiculous amount
of money
uh ridiculous amount of buys it's not
even in the top i don't think 25 of all
time but it's around there
and it's fully made 65 million he made
10 15 20 million dollars so
obviously the model works um and i agree
i think you're right the one thing
that's uh fascinating i wrote about the
other day was have you seen what house
highlights is doing
no how's the highlights so you know who
they are right the the instagram
instagram account uh i think they have
like 25 million followers
it's very good very well done so the
story behind house highlights is cool it
was a student
at central florida omar who started the
account he basically was looking for
uh lebron james was leaving miami heat
at the time and he was going back to
cleveland
and he was looking for highlights of not
them in the game but like the antics
they were doing on the sidelines and in
the locker room and all the stuff you
like heard about and saw sometimes but
he couldn't find him anywhere so he went
to youtube couldn't find it i went to
twitter couldn't find him and all this
stuff was on instagram couldn't find him
so he was like all right i'm gonna start
a page
and they do some highlights they do kind
of the cool plays and stuff like that
but if you actually look at their page
most of it is
uh outside of that kind of stuff so it's
crazy home videos it's trick shots like
dude perfect all these things and
there's
obviously content in the game but the
account blew up 20 million followers
they got purchased by
bleacher report who rolls up to turn and
all this stuff but now what they're
doing instead of just focusing on that
they're
building an entire franchise around live
competitions and it's not live
competitions like we think of with the
nfl or
professional games finding the best
athletes and doing the stuff their bet
is exactly what
uh celebrity boxing is doing we're gonna
find the people that have the largest
audiences
and we're gonna do super relatable games
for high cash prizes and so what it is
is they've done a couple now they did a
golf tournament which was basically just
like a longest i think it was either
longest driver closest to the pin but
some kind of backyard golf tournament
they did a free throw competition and
their next one's a dodgeball tournament
so the the the free throw competition
they just got a bunch of individual
creators right with large audiences hey
you have a million followers on here you
have two million here whatever
put them all in a free throw competition
winner got a hundred thousand dollars
and the next one is a dodge ball right
where winner gets 250 000 but what
they're doing is they're taking all
these like groups right so faze clan and
all these people that have these massive
audiences
and they're pitting them against each
other so not only do you get
the core audience from that group to
come but you're usually these people
don't interact right so when you put
them against kind of a competitor or
someone who does something similar to
them on the internet and you put them
against each other
doing dodgeball attracts the audience
everyone's engaged all this type of
stuff
so their whole idea is like super uh
engaged audiences coming from large
uh large creators have live competitions
make it a relatable game that uri could
play
dodgeball uh closest to the hole in golf
and free throws
and then have high cash prizes right
super low cost to put on
you pay the creators or whatever and
then they're doing the dodgeball
tournament in the uh warner brothers
parking lot
i think that's where they're doing it
which is like you know it's great it's a
dodge you just need an area that you
could do it in the park right
uh and that's essentially what they're
doing so it'll be fascinating to see
this is the third one i think the
the first two they didn't have any major
sponsors this one sponsored by i think
pizza hut or something like that so
they got a sponsor they're monetizing it
and then the interesting part is like
what they did with merchandise and
products off of all that right and it's
you know only the third iteration
but you could quickly see when you look
at celebrity boxing and this like how
they merge together of like
people just want to watch people that
they know compete in these things and
sports is one avenue there's a million
different other ways to do it but it's
fascinating to see them kind of combine
the two and and try to build franchises
out of it
it's gonna be unreal to watch all this
unfold it's like a no-brainer and then
all of a sudden if you start to
layer not only athletes then you talk
about some of these internet
you know communities then you get
musicians then you get business people
like you just start bringing all these
people together
and you literally can't look away like
you have to watch yeah
well the internet did an incredible job
of not only giving you exposure to these
people but being able to build up the
the kind of momentum and attention
towards these events right so
you think about boxing match you
announce it a few months beforehand
you do the weigh-ins there's gotcha hat
right like it was just
incredible content right and the one
clip of logan when he left the fight was
like thanks jake for selling the fight
for me right because that's exactly what
it was what he said yeah he said thanks
right like because that's exactly what
it was he flew in got it they got in a
scuffle it went
viral on the internet espn's posted
about it all these you know people are
posting about it
uh and it just drives attention towards
the event is jake paul the best marketer
on the internet right now
one of them for sure i mean and people
hate it because of
his past and who he is and same thing
right but you got to separate the two
may have done some terrible things
whatever you don't always agree with
that kind of stuff
incredible market or sure whatever
there's probably a middle ground and he
and that's where he is right is like he
does an incredible job of building up
kind of the
anticipation for these events um now the
ufc guys used to hate him because like
this guy's ruining our sport and now
he's arguing against dana white for them
to get paid more so like yeah he's all
right
yeah they're like yeah we like him a
little bit yeah that jake paul guy's got
a point i think that guy actually is
pretty intelligent
dana yeah would you say back to him okay
yeah is dana white the best kind of like
league uh mastermind out of all these
he's great i yeah i mean he's would the
nfl be better off
if dana white was running it it's tough
to say because the nfl's
like roger goodell gets paid you know 50
million bucks a year for a reason
right uh he obviously does an incredible
job and he works for the for the owners
and they obviously like him and they
continue to move him over
but dana white's incredible right he
took a sport that it started in like
1992
uh the first how he's laughing about the
first ufc competition there was no rules
like literally no yeah it's just a
street fight and and the cop no gloves
right
no uh some people were wearing like one
glove some wouldn't wear and
like it was just mayhem and what they
were doing was they were bringing people
from all these different disciplines
right jujitsu taekwondo
straight fighters uh and just putting
them in a ring sumo wrestlers no judges
right so like it could not end unless it
was a knockout or someone gave up
uh and there was just no rules right so
it was kind of barbaric
uh i think uh uh john mccain called it
human [ __ ] fighting and he was like i'll
never let this get
anywhere um and it has obviously dana
white bought it for i think it was two
million bucks or whatever it's
you know almost a 10 billion dollar
company now but one of the things dan
white did really well was
he understood really really early on
what everyone understands now very
clearly which is the audience and the
attention
um when they were struggling they were
about to go bankrupt they had already
pumped like 60 million dollars into
it on top of what they bought the
company for and the fertitta brothers
were like hey you know we need to start
seeing some progress here
uh so he had the ultimate fighter he
came up with the tv show if people
remember it on spike tv
but what people don't know about it was
that he went to like five or six
different networks at first
and we're like hey we want to do the
show you guys do whatever and everyone
said no like this is
because remember it was barbaric at the
time no one watched it everyone thought
it was like kind of ridiculous and
whatever and we've come to kind of be
uh immune to that to some degree right
like we don't think about that as much
anymore but at the time no one wanted to
touch it he said
um okay spike tv i'll pay the 10 million
ourselves
we'll invest 10 million dollars for the
production we'll pay for everything you
guys just put it on tv
they put it on tv maybe there was some
kind of like revenue whatever it might
be but
he paid 10 million bucks to get it
produced shows a hit they went from
doing like 50 000 or 100 000
pay-per-view values they did a million
the next year on an event
wow so crazy just of just getting in
front of people because i don't even
think it was necessarily as much about
just getting more eyeballs on the sport
it was showing that the fighters are
actual people right and you were seeing
people
uh kind of in their in their bed calling
their wife training all day saying hey
look i really need to win this next
fight to make paychecks to be able to
buy us
and all this stuff right so you just see
that human aspect of the fighters so i
think that was incredible but the other
one that
is even less talked about was when all
these leagues remember when twitter was
like
younger right 08 10 whatever uh leagues
were banning or finding people for
saying anything basically on twitter you
just couldn't unless it was like
promotional tweets and like building
your brand like they didn't want
anything and it's completely changed
kind of perception
but the nfl was handing out fines nba
was handing out fines they just
generally didn't really want you to do
it
uh just scared kind of what you would
say dana white actually created a fund
and he said i'm going to hand out cash
payments to whoever tweets the most
and whoever gets the most followers he
had a bunch of metrics that was
basically like i'm going to give you 5
000 10
000 50 000 whatever uh to whoever has
the best performance on twitter
this month or this quarter and what it
did was it just built up the sport right
and
guys like mcgregor now uh it obviously
wasn't as big then but it's exactly what
they
what they've the approach they've taken
of kind of like just having these
fighters build up their personas on
twitter
and attracting an audience showing their
human and that was off the heels of the
ultimate fighter and show
seeing how uh kind of the success of
that show parlayed the success of the
ufc so i thought that was cool
i mean that's crazy yeah that he's
really paying for the winner to be
active on twitter
i mean should i be rich if that was the
case
[Laughter]
all right where can we send people to
find you on the internet where where
should they
actually go to twitter email yeah i mean
twitter's uh
what's your twitter the easiest at joe
pompliano i mean you're the second best
pomp account
on twitter behind john pomp well from a
quality perspective
john's in the room he just gave me a
little you know yeah john's got a good
twitter account he's the numbers guy
uh yeah i mean how much of your content
does john find for you
zero i was gonna i was gonna lie
but i uh and give him the benefit of the
doubt but this is gonna be recorded and
etched in history so
let's uh let's stick with zero all right
just making sure so at
joe pompliano yeah all right and then
email
you send it what every morning every
morning monday through friday uh
i mean listen to 9 30. let me let me
just i'll just say this
so i wake up and i write mine in like 30
minutes like i'm just like
done send it's great people love it big
audience like highly engaged big open
rate you know i'm not gonna brag but
like pretty good
and then joe you wake up what 5 30 and
it takes you
four hours to write this and one day i
was like man what is this guy writing
about
right now i never read it but i never
read it so i went and i read it
and i should remove you from the list
and it was actually good like i was
surprised
and i was like oh this is why it takes
them four hours to write this because
you actually do research and there's
numbers and data it's like it's actually
very good
but it does take you four hours which
makes it me uh like to give you [ __ ] for
it
uh but where can they go to sign up for
the email uh
thanks for that intro for the for the
letter uh read huddle up dot com
read huddle up down read huddle up dot
com all right hold up huddle up
like that like that like the like the
quarterback calling everyone hold up
that was the idea behind the name
was it really yeah yeah yeah and then do
you say like you know uh i don't ever
say it like that well
how do you say it huddle up oh you say
like normal yeah yeah
the quarterback always you know huddle
up huddle up and then everyone comes
together and he's like all right
on two on two ready break we know how it
works
all right go follow him at joe pompliano
go subscribe at read huddle up dot com
you can even say hold up huddle up
and we'll do it again in the future